We have to read a lot in
order to get better at the
language that we're learning.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today, and I'm going to talk, this is
the second in my series of videos about
my hierarchy of goals, the main goals
that I have when I learn a language, and
today I'm going to talk about reading.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you follow on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
So, uh, the first sort of goal that the,
you know, I've worked towards in learning
languages is to acquire words and bear
in mind that all these different goals
are very much interrelated, but these
are sort of the goals that I pursue.
The second goal is
reading and I'll explain.
In order to learn words, we,
first of all, have to read them.
It's a lot...
I don't say we have to, we can also
hear them and eventually learn them,
but it's an awful lot easier in my
experience if I can also read them.
If I just hear them, it's
difficult for me to remember them.
Reading gives them form.
Uh, it's easier for me
to remember the word.
I identify the written word
with the word that I hear.
Um, reading is easier than listening.
I can work my way through a text
at LingQ, look up every word.
Let's say I'm in sentence mode, it's
a brand new language and if there's
seven words in that sentence, I can
look up each word and I can kind of
figure out what the sentence means.
Fuzzy, maybe not totally clear, but I
have a sense of what that sentence means.
I have a sense of which words,
you know, correspond to the
verb, to the noun and so forth.
So the reading is easy.
If I just heard, heard those words,
I wouldn't be able to do that.
So reading is a sort of a step towards
being able to understand what you hear.
This is interesting because of course,
historically, and from an evolutionary
perspective, we weren't, as, as human
beings, we weren't designed to read.
Uh, for the vast majority of our
existence, even as you know, our
ancestors, uh, you know, in the
evolutionary chain and even as human
beings, it's only in the last 5,000
years that writing has existed.
And for most of that period, a very
small percentage of the population
read, books were very expensive.
It was very expensive to print.
This became, you know, it became
more widespread with the development
of different methods of printing
initially in China and then
in Europe with, um, Gutenberg.
And so...
but, and, but even after that, it was
a small percentage of people who read.
So for the human brain to be able to
decipher, to convert sort of written
lines or, uh, drawings, uh, in a text
to convert that into meaning and also
into sound is an amazing achievement.
Uh, and so for us, when we learn to
write even in our own language, that's
a major, um, process, uh, in terms of
getting our brains to adapt to something
that they weren't used to doing.
And many people have difficulty reading.
Uh, now, to make reading easier I've
always felt that it's important to
combine the audio with the reading so
that, you know, it's like, if you're
playing um, a musical instrument if
you have heard the tune, it's easier
to play that tune on the piano or
on the guitar, whatever it might be,
because you have an idea of what it is.
You're trying to, what sort of
music you're trying to make.
Similarly with reading if you can
hear what it is you're trying to
read, you have a little bit of
momentum going into the reading.
So I always combine audio with text.
I, I certainly in an early stage
in my learning, I want to be able
to do both listen and read, but I
know that in order to get good at
the language, I have to read a lot.
And if I look at my statistics in LingQ
uh, even in Arabic and Persian, which
are the two most recent languages, I've
read about 500,000 words in each of them,
and LingQ measures uh, not only when you
read something for the first time, but
also when you read it for a second and
the third time, which I do, and I'll get
into this sort of strategy of reading.
But even when I feel that I'm struggling
to make progress, I know that every
time I'm doing either something new,
which therefore would have a lot of
unknown words that I'm looking up, you
know, blue words, or if I'm rereading
something that I've read before, because
there's still lots of words that are
now yellow words that I have looked
up, but I still don't know those words.
And it's just a process of reading
again, reading something that I've read.
I'm consuming those words.
My brain is slowly, slowly getting
used to reading in that language.
Uh, this is particularly true if
the writing system is different.
And, uh, even though say the
Cyrillic alphabet, which is used for
Russian and Ukrainian, Tajik other
languages, um, is not that different
from our, uh, Latin alphabet.
But if I'm reading in Arabic or Persian,
Or Korean or Japanese or Chinese, every
time I'm reading, I'm helping the brain
get used to this new writing system.
Even if I know theoretically what
the letters represent, I continue
to confuse them because there I'm
still fighting to decipher them.
Whereas if I'm reading them in my own
language or my own writing system,
it's instant, the, the, you know, the
meaning of those letters is, is instant.
Um, and, and I think this might be
similar to, you know, the situation
of people who struggle with dyslexia.
And so they're fighting to decipher
each word whereas a fluent reader just
immediately converts the word to meaning.
Uh, when we're reading in a foreign
language, I find that we're always
sub vocalizing, so that the sound
of the word is very important to us.
Uh, when we read it in our own language,
um, I think it's just an instant meaning.
How did we get that way?
Because ever since childhood,
we've been reading in that
writing system in that language.
And so it's just, it's just a matter
of the brain is so used to it.
So therefore we have to read a
lot in order to get better at
the language that we're learning.
So if I say I'm at 500,000 words in
Arabic or Persian, I had a million
and a half words read at least
according to statistics on LingQ in
languages, like say Czech or Russian,
this doesn't account for the reading
that I do away from the computer.
Again, I read on my iPad or in LingQ in
order to look up words because I, I find
it frustrating to be reading, uh, and, and
having a lot of words that I don't know.
But once I get good enough in a
language, I like to read on paper because
that's, you know, you have no help.
You have, there's no audio,
there's no text to speech.
You can't look up words.
You just have to fight your
way through this text on paper.
And I've always felt that when I am
first able to read a whole book from
cover to cover paper book, conventional
book in a language, that's a major
achievement, a major milestone.
I'm not there in Arabic and Persian.
There are just far too many words that
I don't know, but I continue reading.
That's probably, you know, every day
I read some and either I'm looking up
words because it's, you know, there's
a lot of blue words, unknown words, or
it's material that I've read before.
Perhaps moving some of the
yellow words along and status
moving them perhaps to known.
So I spend a lot of time reading and,
you know, because it's so often the
case in language learning once we
get past that first stage where we
suddenly discover this language and
we understand a few things and we can
say a few things and we're very happy,
then we hit that long period where
we're slowly acquiring these, you know,
lower frequency words, which we know.
So during that period, it's very important
to have a sort of a reinforcement to
convince yourself that you're actually
doing something and I'm getting somewhere.
And, and I've always felt that,
you know, we need measures of
our activity level because if we
are active, we will be learning.
And in that regard to the number
of words, read, which we track at
LingQ, uh, even the number of words,
you know, that you have looked up.
In other words, the LingQs create.
These are all indicators
of how active you are.
And so the reading is a
big activity at LingQ.
It's one that's helping your brain get
used to the language and it's a measure
of how active you are with the language.
And, uh, I will get onto the other
goals like listening, uh, which
is easier to do because I can do
it while I'm doing other tasks.
But reading does require actually being
in front of either be reading from
the book or you're reading on the iPad
or on the computer or using LingQ, or
you're using some other method to read.
It's something that is dedicated.
You cannot be reading and
driving at the same time.
I don't recommend that.
Uh, so, but reading, uh, you know, it's,
it's it's, if we look at reading aside
from language, Illiteracy, um, people
who read well by and large do better.
That's not to say that people who
don't read well are bad people, many
people who don't read well are very
successful in a variety of fields.
Over all people who read well do
better, you know, academically,
professionally, socially, and so forth.
So reading is very important and
people who read well, read a lot
and the same with language learning.
If you want to learn the language
well, you need to read a lot.
And the reading can be either rereading,
you know, easy material, which I
still find myself doing both, you
know, uh, some of the learner books
in Persian, I still read through.
Because to reinforce certain structures
of the language and a, and I'll read
the mini stories again, uh, because
there's still words there that I still
can't remember, but I'm, I vary that
with, you know, reading new material
that has more blue words in it.
And of course the, the feeling we have
when we see that the pages, even if
I, if I bring in a newspaper article
in Persian and I see that the pages
there's fewer and fewer blue words.
Uh, there are more and more
white words that are known.
So you have that sense of the,
the pages on LingQ becoming
lighter and lighter in color.
And that's an indication that
you are getting somewhere, even
though at times you may struggle to
understand you may struggle to speak.
So I guess my message is that, that
in my hierarchy of goals, if the first
goal is to acquire more words, Uh, the
main way of acquiring that, those new
words, passive vocabulary is reading,
reading in combination with listening,
but I can't do it without the reading.
And the amount of reading we
do on LingQ is easily measured.
So it's, it's sort of a
measure of how active you are.
It's an indication that you are
moving forward in the language, even
though sometimes you think you aren't.
And even if I'm reading something,
that's relatively uninteresting.
Something that I've read before.
I know from personal experience that just
being exposed to this, to the writing
system, being exposed to this need to
read and to decipher what's written there.
And that's helping me.
So, I mean, we will do things.
I regularly pull down a kettle 20
minute, 25 minute kettlebell routine
from YouTube that I've done before, but
I know that it's good for me to do it.
So I'm, I'm content to do it.
Uh, the same with reading material
that I've read before and our system
at LingQ does keep track of that.
But at the same time, I'm motivated,
motivated to read new material where I'll
acquire new words and where I'm learning
about things that are of interest to me.
So you can do both kinds of reading.
You can be reading specifically to learn
sort of a deliberate learning activity,
or you can be reading to acquire more
information, to learn about different
things that are of interest to you.
But again, reading, uh,
whether you do it a digit...
you know, with e-text or whether
you do it in a paper book is is a
fundamental part of language learning.
Now that's not to say that there
aren't lots of people who learn and
don't read, and I am sure there are,
we read about the, you know, the
Amazon jungle, where there's so many
different languages and people managed
to learn each other's languages.
I gather in Ethiopia, which is not a
country with a high rate of literacy uh,
people nevertheless are quite multilingual
because there are so many languages
there, so you can learn without reading.
However, it's easier with reading.
If you live surrounded by speakers
of other languages, you'll pick up
those languages quite comfortably, but
most of us aren't in that situation.
And so reading, which is a, it's
like a recording, but it's a written
record of what someone's said.
Uh, better.
If you can hear what's there, because
that gives you momentum into the
reading, you actually can hear the
words that you're reading, but to have
the ability to read in combination
with listening is very, very powerful.
So, uh, and in my mind, you know,
in terms of the statistics that I
follow, uh, at LingQ of my reading
comes right after, um, my vocabulary.
So I hope that was helpful.
And I will continue in this series
about my goals when I learn languages.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.